근데 여기서 우리가 얘기하고 싶은
건이 버블이란 얘기예요.
>> 그러니까 아까도 버블이
>> 버블 누가 버블인가는 판단하지
못한다. 결국엔 이런 식으로 났을 때
버블이라고 우리가 얘기할 수 있다.
그래서 이제 근거를 두 가지
얘기했는데 어떻게 생각하세요?이 이
버의 개념은 뭡니까?
>> 아니요. 권대님한테 물어봤어요.
아,
>> 그니까 투자자가 느끼는 법을이라고
한다면
>> 이게 뭐 뭐 학문적인 법 그 이런 그
정의 말고 투자자가 느끼는 건 그거
아닐까요? 이익이 어, 그러니까
주가가
주가는 높은데 돈은 못 버는 거죠.
>> 음. 음,
>> 일반적인 투자자분들은 그렇게 느낄
겁니다. 그래서 미래 가치를 계속
당겨오기만 해서 미래에 돈 벌 거야.
앞으로 시장이 좋아질 거야라는
기대감만으로 주가를 올려 놨는데
그러면 허상인 거잖아요.
>> 어, 그렇게 된다면 버블이다라고
느끼는 거 아닐까요?
>> 그러니까 주가는 올라왔는데 그만큼
이익이 안 따라주면 버블이다. 자,
박수 대표님은 이익을 어떻게
규정하세요? 버블을네. 뭐 버블을
정하는 거는 뭐 이런 지표 저런
지표로 다 정하기든 하더라고요. 근데
제가 이제 버블론이 나올 때 항상항상
드리는 말씀은
>> 버블이라고 치자.
>> 응.
>> 쳐. 근데 버블 초입이면 법을 안
즐길 거야. 저는 약간 그런 생각을
하고 있어요. 왜냐면
>> 어 버블이 붕괴되는 그때까지 사실은
주식이 엄청 오르거든요.
더 많이 오르잖아요. 막 갈수록
그죠.
>> 그걸 안 즐길 거야. 어
>> 그래서
>> 사실은 언제 터질지 모르긴 합니다만은
버블이라고 쳐도
>> 어 버블이라고 쳐도 이게이 버블이
언제 끝날지 모르지만 그 모르는 끝을
향해서 갈 때까진 가야 된다. 아
약간 그런 생각을 하고 있고요.
>> 지금 근데 이제 시장에서 나오는
버블론는 야 이거 옛날에 닷컴버블
터질 때하고 비슷해. 그때도 뭐 뒤에
닷컴 뭐 무슨 무슨
>> 인터넷 무슨무슨 뭐만 걸고 있으면 다
올랐어. 뭐 그래서 어 그런에서가
보니까 뭐 참고 컴퓨터 앉아 놓고
하는 애들도 막 어 엄청나게 평가
많이 받았어. 지금 거의 그런 거랑
유사할지도 몰라. 이게 이제 버블론의
핵심인데
>> 제가 볼 때는 그때랑 다른 점이
있어요. 아니 그때랑 유사한 점
하나는 뭐냐면 일단은 소수의 기업으로
집중돼 가지고 돈과 주가 상승률이
엄청 몰리고 있어요. 그래서 어 이거
그 그때처럼 위험한 거 아니야? 너무
많이 오르고 있잖아.
>> 그리고 걔네들 돈 너무 많이 쓰고
있어. 그건 좀 유사해 보여요.
>> 네. 근데 이제 그때랑 다른 점이
있다는 거예. 제가 볼 때는. 어,
뭐가 다르냐면은 그때는 돈을 못
벌었어요.
>> 음.
>> 실적이 안
>> 실적이 없어요. 근데 지금 이제
AI라든지 반도체라든지 이런 회사들은
실적도 있고 실체도 있어요. 제가 볼
때는.
>> 예. 지금 우리가 제미나이 오픈 AI
GPT 이걸 보고 있단 말이에요.
예. 예. 근데 그때는 뭐 한대, 뭐
한대라고 하면 그냥 뭐 대충 이렇게
해놓고 말고 하는 회사들
많았었거든요. 그러니까 실적도 있고
실적도 있다. 이런 말씀을 좀 드리고
실제로
어 전 요게 좀 중요하다고 보는데
만약에 쭉 가다가
실적과 실제가 있어도 중간에 부러지는
회사가 나오겠죠. 왕주화의 자리를
차지하지 못하는 자리들이 있겠죠.
그럼 걔네들이 했던 서비스나 데이터
센터나 깔아놨던 전력망이나 이런게
없어지냐 이거예요. 제가 볼 때는
살아남은 자들에게 흡수되면서
가거든요. 그래서이
>> 모든 생태계가 다 작살 끝나는게 법을
붕괴고
>> 더어 부러지는 회사는 나오더라도이
>> 회사들이 남겨 놓은 인프라 자산 유산
>> 흔적들이 흡수되면서
AI 시대를 계속 이끌고 가지
않을까? 아, 너무 좋은데.
>> 그니까 개별적으로 손해보는 주주는
있어도이 생태계의 버블을 논하기에는
>> 아직은 뭐 전혀 다르다. 저는 그
>> 한 가지만 더 덧붙여 드리면 과거
버블과 뭐가 다르냐라고 했을 때 첫
번째가이 실적과 실체고요. 두 번째는
고용입니다.
>> 고용.
>> 그때는 다버일 때는
>> 사업한다.
>> 고용해.
>> 이렇게 이야기를 했다는 거예요. 일단
사람을 붙여.
>> 음.
>> 막 그래서 고용이 그때도 늘었죠.
>> 근데 지금은 어떻습니까? AI로
고용을 줄입니다.
>> 음.
>> 그러니까 소위 말해서 이게 참 저도
일하는 입장에서 말하긴 어렵습니다만
노동자가
줄고 인건비가 크게 나가지 않는다라는
거예요.
>> 음.
>> 하드웨어를 까는 데는 돈이 들지만
고정적으로 나가는 인건비가 커지지
않는다라는 것도 다르다라고
평가합니다. 네.
>> 어. 그러니까 이게 굉장히 흥미로운
점을 두 분이 말씀하 해 주셨어요.
박수 대표님은 이게 과거하고 다른게
뭐냐면 유산이 남는다. 그래서 이걸
누군가 활용하고 그게 인프라는 거죠.
권커님은이
투자가 이어지는데 비용이 따라 오르지
않고 있다. 그래서 어 부담이 좀
적은 거 아니냐이 말씀하셨어요.
그런데이 두 분의 말씀이 주식
시장에서 가장 싫어하는 말이에요.
>> 음
>> 뭐냐면 과거와 다르다고 얘기할 때
항상 법부이라고 생각합니다.
>> 음.
>> 과거와 달라. 이제는 달라.이
얘기를 하면서 항상 주식 시장에서
뭐라고 얘기하냐면 이런 얘기 많이 할
때 조심해야 돼라고 얘기하죠. 네.
>> 그런데요.
저는 그거는 수사적인 그냥 단순히
수사적인 말이라고 생각해요. 어,
진짜 세상을 바꾸는 건 과거와 달라야
세상을 바꿔요.
>> 네.
>> 그리고 그런 일들이 그동안 많았단
말이에요. 근데 우리는 버블이 터진
것만 보니까 그때 그런 얘기를
했었잖아. 음.
>> 아니요. 우리는 수십년 동안 매일 그
얘기를 해왔다고요. 그런데 그
시점에만 뽑아 놓으니까
>> 확대해서 해석하는 거죠. 그때도
그렇게 얘기했잖아.
>> 아, 맞아요.
>> 아니, 그러면 지난해 말 때도요.
우리 코스피 어, 지금과 다르다라고
얘기했어요. 맨날 그랬잖아. 그러면
맨날 버블이었어요. 아, 제가 이제
화내 되는 건 아니고
>> 지금 오프닝한테 20분 됐습니다.
>> 그니까 여러분들이 이런 수사에 자꾸
투자를 흔들리면 안 된다. 그 말씀을
드리고 싶었고.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 이제 저의 개념 정은 뭐냐면
버블은
>> 꺼져야 알 수 있어요. 그렇죠.
>> 꺼지지 않으면 버블 아니에요.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 예. 그래서 우리가
>> 꺼질 때까지 간다.
>> 네. 대표님은 버블 아니다. 저는
버블이어도 지금은 새벽이야. 아,
좋습니다.
여러분 안녕하십니까? 여러분의 밥
친구가 되고 싶은 네. 경제 1타
강사 설명재 박시동입니다.
네. 늘 보시던 그 얼굴 버럭 광수,
술톤 광수, 양봉 광수가 아니고 네가
왜 거기 있냐? 네. 죄송합니다.
네. 여러분이 많이 기다려 주셨을
텐데요. 아, 지금 댓글 보니까 아,
이광수 대표님, 이광수 형님 지금
많이 아프신가 보다. 괄로 또 어저께
다른 방송에서도 보니까 목소리가 너무
안 좋던데 쓰러지셨나 이런 아,
댓글들이 지금 많이 올라오고 계세요.
어, 그러면서 우리 병문한 가자
등등등해서 거의 지금 중환자 느낌
나고 있거든요. 그런 상황 아니고요.
멀쩡하시고요. 예. 아, 이광수
대표님이 개인적으로 차력이 엄청
좋으세요. 예. 예. 아무리이 과음을
해도 새벽 내 벌떡 일어나십니다.
예.
>> 끈기와 금면 성실로 다져진
인생이거든요. 예. 몸이 아프신 건
아니고요. 음. 저희가 몇 번
말씀드립니다만 저희가이 프로그램 런칭
전에 잡아 놓은 피치모터 스케줄들이
있어요. 저도 사실 9월 강연까지
아직 잡힌게 있거든요. 저
>> 저도 다음 주에
>> 네. 잘라고 좀 해 봅니다. 근데
이제 공익적인 행사라서 오늘 피치
못하게 예 자리를 떴고요. 그럼에도
불구하고 저희는 꿋꿋하게 해
나갑니다. 그렇죠.
>> 예. 그럼요.
>> 예. 저희가 이제 이광수 대표님의 빈
자리를 학 채우기 위해서
>> 멀쩡하게 더 돌아왔습니다.
>> 네. 저희 둘이 오늘 열심히 해
보도록 하겠습니다. 네. 크림 같은
여자 건다영 왔습니다, 여러분.
>> 부드러운 여자 자리 지키고 있습니다.
네.
>> 그래서 또 오늘 화이트톤으로
>> 네. 오늘 화이트톤으로
>> 네. 그런 느낌으로. 아이 좋습니다.
자, 그런데 오늘 아침에 저희는 제가
참 방송을 못 보긴 했는데
>> 뉴스 공장에서 오늘 뭐 8, 못
넘으면은 우리보고 책임지라고 그랬다고
들으셨어요?
>> 어. 예. 그래서 그 짧게 잘라
주셔서 스텝께서 봤는데 오늘 8차피
못 넘으면 뭐 12시에서 만나면서
책임져 뭐 이런 식으로 얘기를 머리를
막 넘기시면서 하셨는데 아니 저희
오늘 제가 대본 보니까 저희 이제
20회했어요.
>> 근데 저희의 일자리를 없애려고 하시
공장님 왜 왜 그러시는 거예요?
지금요 저희 우리이 2시에 만나기
때문에 뉴스 공장이 겸손 힘들다.
채널 전체 구독자도 들고 있고 우리가
효자입니다.
>> 아 효자인데
>> 좀 세게 나가도 돼요. 예 아무튼
오늘 8초을 넘을까 못 넘을까 많은
분들이 관심을 갖고 있었는데네
>> 일단 넘기는 넘었었어요. 근데 다시
또 조금 아리까리한데요. 자 이런
상황들 우리 권다영앵행코 님이
준비하신 뉴스와 함께 알아보도록
하겠습니다.네
>> 분위기 함께 먼저 살펴보도록
하겠습니다. 현재 코스피 지수 같은
경우는 3%대 하락세 나타나고
있습니다. 7,710포인트
수준 왔다 갔다 하고 있고요. 코스닥
같은 경우도 2.6%대 하락으로 현재
1159포인트 지나갑니다. 아,
외국인 매도가 남아서 계속해서 환율에
대해서 말씀을 드릴 수밖에 없는데요.
현재 외국인이 코스피 시장에서 3조원
넘게 매도하고 있고요. 환율은
1,499원, 1500원선 목전에
두고 있습니다. 뉴스들 먼저
살펴보도록 하겠습니다. 일단 장
초반에 분위기가 굉장히 좋았습니다.
7거레일 그니까 7,000 찍고
7거래일 만에 8,000 기록
성공했습니다. 초고속 랠리였다라고
하는데 장중에 8,046포인트 찍고
지금 어 급락이라고 느껴질 만한 지금
상황입니다. 어떤 뉴스들이 있는지 왜
하락하는지 이유 찾아보도록
하겠습니다. 두 번째로는 엔비디아
이야기데요.음 음. 원래는 지금
H200을 중국에 팔 수 있다라는
이야기가 나오면서 미국장에서 4%
이상의 급등을 보였습니다. 하지만
1번 뉴스와 함께 엮어서 여기서도
뭔가 잡음이 지금 나오고 있거든요.
자세한 내용 살펴보도록 하겠습니다.
아, 세 번째 뉴스는 지금 AI
반도체 신흥 강좌 종목이 미국
나스닥에 데뷔를 했습니다. 어,
세레브레스라는
종목인데요.이 이 종목이 상장함으로써
어떤 어 수급의 변화를 유도하게 될지
삼성전자 SK닉스 영향보도록
하겠습니다.
마지막으로는 오늘 많이 빠지고 있는
어 전력 설비 관련된 종목들 그리고
전선 관련된 종목들의 흐름을 좀
체크를 해 봐야 될 것 같습니다.
현재 전선 전력 설비 관련된 종목들
적게는 45%에서 10% 넘게
급락하고 있다는 점 정리해 드립니다.
지금까지 정호의 머니 뉴스였습니다.
네. 또 오늘 이렇게 깔끔하게 예.
정리를 해 오셨는데요. 일단은 뭐
코스피 전체적인 지수 얘기를 해 봐야
되겠죠.
>> 아, 일단은 장초반에 분위기가 너무
좋았어요. 음. 이러다가 8,000
딱 가겠네 했는데 진짜 8천을
갔어요. 그래서 8,046포인트까지
기록을 하면서 좋았다가
>> 네. 아, 한 하락으로 전환이 된게
한 10시 반 뭐 11시 요때부터 막
꺾기 시작하더니 현재도 3% 이상의
약세를 보여주고 있습니다. 여러 가지
뉴스가 많기는
>> 한데음
>> 첫 번째로 살펴볼 건 트럼프 대통령의
언급입니다. 이란에 대해서 더 이상의
인내심을 가지지 않겠다라고 이야기를
하게 되면서 유가가 장중의 상승으로
더 틀어내고 있습니다. 안 그래도
어제 미중정상 회담했잖아요.
>> 네. 거기서 어 호르무즈 열겠다라는
것을 미중 모두 이야기를 했음에도
불구하고 유가가 안 내려갔거든요.
>> 계속 언급을 하는데도 지금 유가가
떨어지지 않고 있다가 첫 번째 이유로
꼽히고 있고요.
>> 두 번째로는 미중 정상 회담에 진짜
알맹이가 있는게 맞아 이겁니다. 음.
>> 네.
>> 왜냐면 보잉이 오늘 미국장에서 하락을
했어요.
>> 아
>> 원래는 500대 정도 항공기를 사 줄
거야라고 기대를 했는데
>> 100대 사 준다 그런 거예요.
>> 아이고야. 어 그래서 어 뭐야 왜
이거밖에 안 사 하는 상황 속에서
>> 지금 외신 쪽에서 미국의 무역 대표부
대표의 인터뷰가 진행 전해지고
있습니다. 어, 미국 무역 대표부의
제이슨 그리어가 인터뷰를 했는데 미중
양자 회담에서 미국의 대중 반도체
수출 통제 문제가 주요 의제로
다뤄지지 않았고 해당 주제에 대한
심층 논의는 없었다라고 하면서 현재
아시아 시장 전반적으로 밀려가고
있고요. 여기서 특징적인 것은 어제
많이 하락했었던 중국의 반도체주들이
상승으로 전환됐다라는 겁니다. 그래서
이것이 삼성전자와 SK 하이닉스의
하락 원인이라고 꼽혀지고 있고요.
음. 뭐 삼성전자의 파업 이슈도
계속해서 이어지고 있습니다.
>> 네. 그러니까 사실은 어저께 일단
미중 정상 회담이 있었고 처음에는
분위기가 그래도 어 세계가 아
주목하는 맛처럼 호르무제 해업 열어야
된다.
>> 네.
그리고 뭐 반도체 관련해서도 예를
들어서
아 이게 좀 중요한데요. 당초에는
이제 미국이 반도체 장비 또 어
주요한 반도체 중국을 통제했는데
>> 그동안 어떤 일이 있었냐면
>> 야 적가형은 내가 또 저 어 좀 범용
좀 낮은 사양은 내가 열어 줄게
어라고 해서 소위 말하면 이제
Nv디아의 H200 정도는 열어
줄게라고 미국 일단 오케를 했단
말이에요. 대신에 이제 어 연는
대신에 엔비디아 그걸 수출하면 야
수수료로 정부에 얼마 내 이건
조건이야 그 대신 열어줬지. 이렇게
했는데 사실은 열어주고 나면은
엔비디아 관련한 칩을 중국이 막 어
열성적으로 수입할 것처럼 보였는데
중국이 싫어 됐어.
>> 나 그거 없어도 돼.
>> 어 혼자 할 거야. 이렇게 해서
사실은 이제 정상 수입이 안 되고
있는 상황이었거든요.
그래서 중국이 과연 반도체를 자립할
수 있을 것인가? 이게 과연 가능한가
또는 그게에 미국에게 그렇게 자립의
기회나 동기를 계속 중국에게 주는게
미국의 유리한가? 차라리 미국 쓰게
만들어서 자리 부지가 없이 미국
기술에 종속되게 하는게 더 나은 거
아니야? 이런 어떤 감로 늘박이 있는
중이었는데 어저께 드디어 H200
관련해서 이제 어 수출이 열리나
보다라는 식의 발표 비슷무리한게
나왔었거든요. 그로 인해서 이제 미국
증시도 좋아졌고 엔비디아도 좋아진
상황이었는데 네
>> 방금 권앤행커님 말씀하신 것처럼 어
뚜껑을 열어 보니까 아닌가벼
>> 예 아닌가벼
>> 어라고 해서 어 미국 무역 대표부 어
>> 제이슨 그리어
>> 예 그리어의 멘트에 따르면 반도체
관련한 수출 통제가 테이블에 올라오지
않았고 않았고
>> 그리고 사실은 이게 어떤 의미가
있냐면
>> 네
>> 지금 미국은 열어줬는데
중국이 안 받는다는 거예요. 중국 그
민간 업체들은 받고 싶은데 정부가 야
받지 마.
>> 기술 자립이야. 나 허가 안 한다.
자립해. 이렇게 얘기하고 있는데 그
방침이 빠져야 민간에서도 예 살 수가
있는데 지금 그러면 중국 그러면서
이제 그리어 대표 얘기는 반도체가
테이블에도 올라가지 않았고 수출
통제를 풀 거냐 그니까 수입을 할
거냐 말 거냐는 중국에게 달려 있지.
그게 뭐예요?
>> 결국 회담 전과 별반 달라지게 없다.
>> 아예 없죠. 예. 예. 예. 그러니까
간밤에 우리가 환호했던 건 뭐냐
이렇게 됐다 얘기죠?
>> 그렇죠. 그습니다. 그러면서 어
젠슨이 와서 사실은 기자들과 그 만찬
끝나고 나서 마주쳤어요. 회담
어땠어요라고 기자들이 물어봤을 때
좋았다. 양국 관계가 그레이트하다라는
표현을 썼는데 이것에 대해서 기자들이
미국 무역 대표부 대표에게 또
묻습니다. 그러면은 어 젠슨이
중국이랑 이야기했던 거에는 뭐냐라고
했더니 아 협의를 한 건 맞다.
하지만 구체적인 내용은 뭐 언급을
아예 안 했고 말씀해 주신 대로
엔비디아 칩은 뭐 중국이 산다라고
해야 사는 거 아니냐라는 식의 답변을
했습니다.
>> 네. 네. 그래서 아무튼 우리가 오늘
어저께 이제 그런 어떤 좋은 유화적인
흐름이 있다라고 생각했고 좀 있따
말씀 나누겠습니다만 그래서 NBI도
또 올라가고 했었는데
>> 그래서 장 출발할 때 굉장히 좋을
거야라고 기대를 해서 8,46까지는
갔었는데 지금 우리가 전해드린
속보처럼 어
>> 트럼프 대통령이이란 참지 않겠어?
>> 이런 얘기를 하면서 국제 유가도 다시
100불 이상으로 102 2불까지
올라갔던가요?
>> 네. 현재 W는 102달러 54C에서
거래가 되고 있고요. 거기다가 조금
더 우리가 체크를 해봐야 될 건
유가가 오르고 달러 인덱스가 오르고
국채 금리가 오르는 이거를 좀 봐야
될 거 같죠? 예. 그러니까 지금
유가가 오르고 어저께 우리가 환화했던
반도체 소식도 어 아직은 환호할 때가
아닌가 봐라고 하는 실망. 그리고
유가가 오르니까 말씀처럼 또 달러도
오르고 더군다나 거기다가 최근에
저희가 말씀드린 것처럼 각국의 국채
금리 사정도 조금 예 시장에 압박을
주고 있는데 이것까지 이제 지금
종합적으로 몰리다 보니까
>> 아 환호할 때가 아닌가 봐라고 해서
지금 아시아 증시도 좀 빠지고 있는
거고요. 네.
>> 그리고 이제 미국 관련해서도 오늘
장을 앞둔 선물도 현재 지금 매도
국면이다. 이렇게 봐야 되는 거죠.
네. 네장시아작오를
넘겨내는 모습들 나타나고 있고요.
아시아장 전반적으로 분위기 굉장히
위축되어 있습니다. 현재 니케이 지수
1% 이상의 약세 보여줬고요. 대만
각권도 신나게 출발을 함께 했다가
하락 전환했고요. 상해 종합 지수
같은 경우는 오히려 낙폭을
줄여냅니다.
도체기를 더 강어붙이겠네라고
어제급했던 반도체주들이 올라오고
있다라고 보여집니다.
>> 네. 그리고 이제 방금 저희가 끝
끝에 잠깐 말씀드렸던이 금리 관련한
것도 사실은 증시에 부담을 많이
주거든요, 여러분. 그러니까 금리가
올라간다 그러면
>> 자본 조이 힘들어지겠네. 그다음에
이제에 그 자본에 의지해서 사실은
이제 투자라든지 이런 걸 많이 해야
되는 IT 뭐 바이오 등등등 이런
기술 관련한 산업들은 영향을 많이
받거든요. 지금 금리 상황이 전
세계적으로 지금 아무튼 좋지가
않죠.네 네, 맞습니다. 지금
10년물 미국 기준입니다. 10년물
국채 금리가 오늘 더 올라가네요.
4.513 지나가고 있고요. 이연물
국채 금리도 중요합니다. 왜냐면
이연물 국채 금리가 거의 기준 금리,
미국의 정책 금리를 결정하 큰 영향을
주기 때문입니다. 아, 이연물 현재
4.047.
특히나 미국의 20년 30년물은 뭐
무조건 5위고요. 5% 위인 것이
입찰 때부터 나타나는 모습들 나타나고
있습니다. 일본 30집년물 현재
3.967로
꽤나 상승폭 이어갑니다.
>> 네. 네. 그러니까 이제 금리에
대해서 짧게만 말씀드리면 지금 우리가
지표로 삼는게 미국의 10년
국채인데요. 그게 지금 4.5가
넘으면 항상 미국이 이제
재정부담이라든지 이런 것 때문에
트럼프가 아 금리가 이렇게 높아 그럼
내가 시장 친화적인 어떤 정책이든
메시지를 내야지라고 하면서 꼬리를
내린다라고 해서
>> 트럼프가 예 타코 어가 되는
기준선이다. 우리가 지금 시작했.
음했
4.5를 넘었다는 거잖아요. 연물이.
그러니까 이제 어 시장에서는 사실상
어 금리 위험해라고
하는 알람이 들어왔다 이렇게 보시면
될 거 같고요.
>> 방금 이제 코행컨님 말씀처럼 2년물은
뭐냐면이 만기가 2년이니까 이거는 곧
있으면 돌아오거든요. 그러니까 이제
이거는 연준의 기준 금리와 가장
밀접하게 연동이 돼 있죠. 10년
30년짜리는 지금 우리가 금리를
정해도 30년 있다니까 예, 텀이
긴데 이제 어려운 얘기랑 뭐
듀레이이션 이런게 길긴 한데
2년짜리는 붙어 있거든요. 근데 지금
미국 금리이 기준 금리가 지금 뭐
3.5나 3.7호 왔다리 갔다리
한다고 쳐도 이게 지금 4를
넘어갔다는 거니까
>> 야 이거 뭐 조만간에 올라가는 거
아니야라는 시장의 분위기를 이렇게
반영하고 있으니까 위험한 거고 우리
금리도 지금 굉장히 높죠. 어 우리
금리도 지금 많이 높
>> 많이 높고 그다음에 이제 일본도 지금
>> 역사적으로 가장 높은 구간을 지금
현재 돌파하고 있어요.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 일본 30년물 어때요?
일본 30년물은 현재 3.967
지나가면서 뭐 며칠 오르는 건지 제가
계산이 안 되네요. 한 연속으로 계속
>> 맞습니다. 그러니까 지금 일본이
3.9
97이래 그러면 30년물이 그럼 뭐
미국은 아까 뭐 5라 그러더니 뭐 별
차이 안 나네. 근데 여러분 1번은
금리가 거의 예 0입니다. 0인데
30년이 3이니까 엄청 높은 거예요.
>> 그러니까 지금 어쨌거나이 이런 말이
노이즈가이
여진이 계속 이어지면서 확실하게 이제
미중 회담을 통해서 좀 제압이 돼야
되는데
>> 지금 트럼프가이란 참지 않겠어? 뭐
이런 얘기를 하고 또 이제 이란에서는
트럼프를 상대로 지금 현상금을 걸어
가지고 어떻게 해보겠다 뭐 이런네
>> 뭐 현상금도 걸었고요.이 와중에 또
숟가락 걷는 애들 있죠. 네.
이스라엘 이스라엘도 우리 군사 활동
안 끝났다라고
이야기를 하고 있습니다.
>> 그렇습니다. 그래서 이제 간밤에
분위기 좋았지만
>> 지금 일단 통트고 나서 보니까
>> 씁쓸하거나 쌓해지는 소식들이 좀 몰려
들면서 한 번에 지금음 시장 분위기를
조금 냉각시키고 있다. 요렇게 봐야
될 것 같아요.
>> 맞아요. 그래서 조금은 아까지 트럼프
대통령과 시즌핑 주석이 오후에 회담이
아 시작이 됐군요.
언론 참여공이
또 시작이 됐다라고 지금 소식이
들어오고 있습니다. 그래서 이거
끝나고 나서 진짜
>> 지금 뭐 어떤 이야기가 나오냐면
알맹이가 있는 거냐 없는 거냐 이런
이야기가 나오고 있어서 오늘은 좀
알맹이가 있는 이야기가 나오기를 좀
기다려 보
>> 첫 번째 뉴스만 정리를 간단히 하면
>> 네
>> 악수는 할 했고 약속은 없다. 어
>> 어
>> 시장은 확실한 약속과 이런 걸
원했는데 악서만 하고 아직 약속은
없다. 오후에담 한번 기대해 보고요.
두 번째 뉴스.
>> 네. 두 번째 뉴스는 아마 저희가
이야기를 이미 해서 요거는 좀 넘어가
보도록 하겠습니다. 두 번째 뉴스는
M엔 M비디아의 중국의 H200
판매였고요. 앞에서 다뤘기 때문에 세
번째 뉴스 함께 가보도록 그는 한데
이제 MB 소식 이제 그 H200
관련한 얘기는 저희가 해 드렸는데
어쨌든 그 소식 때문에 NBD가
>> 주가가 많이 올랐어요. 간밤에 일단은
예 그래서 최고가였죠. 네. 4%
이상의 강세 보여주면서
235달러였고요.
>> 와 시가 총액이 여러분 5조
7천억이에요.
>> 5조 7천억.
>> 5조 7천억이요?
>> 예.
>> 달러입니다 여러분. 원
>> 5조 7천억 불이에요.네
>> 달러.
>> 그래서 여러분 참고로 알아보시
알아두셔야 될게 지금의이
시총이 예를 들어서 뭐 일본에
GDP를 넘습니다.
>> 아 그죠. 그렇죠.
>> 어마어마한 거예요. 그리고 여러분
깜짝 놀라실 거예요.
>> 은
>> 전 세계은 시총을 넘었습니다 오늘.
오.
>> 예. 역사적으로 여러분 어디에나
있는게 금. 그리고은 아닙니까?
>> 근데 이제 그죠.
>> 엔비디아가
>> 네.
>> 은의 시총을 넘었대요.
>> 어마어마한 겁니다. 사실.
>> 진짜 대단하군요.
>> 네. 요것까지는 그냥 오늘 분위기가
좋던 말든 상식적으로 알아둡시합니다.
>> 네. 예. 좋은 어쨌든간 엔비디아가
또 달려 줘야 우리나라고 전 세계에
또 AI가 달리는 거니까요. 하지만
마지막으로 덧붙여 드리면 다음 주에
엔비디아 실적 발표 예정되어
있습니다.
>> 네. 세 번째 뉴스 말씀 세 번째
뉴스 함께 보도록 하겠습니다.
>> 요거 참 궁금한데
>> 세레브라스라는
>> 이름이 힘들어요.
>> 조금 어렵죠. 세레브라스라는
종목이 상장을 했어요. 나스닥에
상장을 했고요. 뭐 하는 기업이냐면
초대형 AI 연산용 웨이퍼 스케일칩
너무 어렵죠? 엔비디아가 하는 거랑
비슷한 거 한다. 뭐 이렇게 보시면
될 것 같습니다. 근데 오늘 상장하고
나서 아주 급등을 했어요. 그래서
>> 공모가가 그니까 그러니까 시작하게
우리는이 가격에 상장할 거야 했던 그
가격이 185달러였는데요.
장 중에 380달러 터치하기도
했고요. 결국에는 68% 올라가면서
311달러에서
거래를 마감지었습니다.
IP라고 해서 기업 공개절 그니까
상장 절차를 밟으면서 어 그럼이
회사의 가치는 얼마고 시가 총액은
얼마고 그럼 한 주에 얼마로 할래
이런 걸 계속 조정하잖아요.
>> 이게 IPO 시작되고 나서 계속
올랐어요.
>> 그래서 애초에 이야기했던게 주당
110달러였거든요. 근데 최종
공모가가 185달러였습니다.
그만큼
AI 칩에 대해서 많은 관심을 받고
있다라는 것이 증명됐다라고 하는데
이러면 그러면은 뭐 다 좋은 거야.
이거를 말씀을 하실 거 같아요.
IPO를 하는 것이 과연 시장에 AI
시장에 다 좋은 것이냐에 대해선 한번
좀 약간 고민을 해 봐야 할 지점이
있는 거 같습니다. JP모건에서
IPO 관련된 이야기를 지금 올해
정말 많은 기업들의 IPO가 기다리고
있잖아요.
>> 네. 그래서 이거 괜찮은 거야.
스페이스엑스 상장하면 다른음 빅테크
종목에서 돈 빼고 삼성전자
SK닉스에서 돈 빼서 스페이스엑스
사는 거 아니야.라는 것에 대한
분석을 내놓습니다.
>> 네.
>> 거대 신규 자산의 편입은 기존 M7을
포함한 대형 기술주들의 인덱스 내
비중을 강제로 낮추는 효과를 가져오며
수급상 분산을 요도한다라는 분석을
내놨습니다. 이게 사실
>> 네. 좋은 거라고 해석하기는 어려운
거 아닌가요?
>> 그렇습니다. 저희가 뭐 왜이 뉴스를
그 세 번째 뉴스를 가지고 왔냐면 뭐
미국의 어떤 회사가 또는 뭐 유럽의
어떤 회사가 일본이나 대만의 어떤
회사가 자국에서 새롭게 상장했대.
>> 네.
>> 그러면 그냥 그런가 없다 하고 나는
뭔 상관이야?
>> 나 바빠라고
>> 하는데 요거는 조금 우리가 의미가
있어서 온 거죠. 네. 말씀주신
것처럼 지금 사실은 우리가 AI
생태계속 우리 기업들도 잘되고 있고
삼성 뭐 하이닉스 다 잘되고 있고 그
안에서 우리가 이제 주도주들을 많이
찾아가는게 하나의 흐름이란 말이에요.
>> 그죠?
>> 그래서요 생태기 안에서 뭔 일이 나면
이게 바로 우리 경제, 우리 주식,
우리 주도주들의 영향을 주기 때문에요
생태기 안에서 벌어지는 일들은 좀
보셔야 되는데 어 심상치가 않네 또는
눈여겨 봐야 되네라는 거잖아요.
>> 네. 얘네가 뭐냐면 사실은 이제
Nv디아의 대학마로 꼽혀요.
>> 왜 그러는 거예요?
>> 그런 칩을 만들고 있어서
>> 맞아요. 이제 엔비디아는 사실은 이제
칩을 직접 만들지는 않잖아요. 이제
설계하고 주문은 TSMC에다가도 주고
뭐 이렇게 하는 건데
>> 어 NBDI의 대학마로 꼽히는 이유가
얘네들도 AI 전용 반도체를
설계한다네.
>> 어 그러니까 나도 할 수 있어.
그렇게 반도체가 뭐잖아. 내 설계에
따라서 만들면 얘네들 이거 데이터
센터도 넣을 수 있고 AI 모델 어
구동하는데 쓸 수 있는 칩 만들 수
있어라고 하는 업체가 나왔기 때문에
>> 어떻게 보면 AI 생태계에 또 다른
신흥 대학마가 나온 거 아니냐라고
하면 생태계 전로 보면 어 좀 더
커지는 건가? 다양한 경쟁과 쉽게
말하면 이제 다이나미즘이 생기는
건가?라고
>> 해서 좋게 볼 수도 있죠. 그죠?
그런데 이제 문제는 뭐냐면 여기서
미치는 영향이잖아요.
미디아가 TSMC에게
주로 딱 설계를 해서 맡기고
TSMC는 거기서 쭉 만들면서 거기에
꼭 필요한 HBM을 하이닉스로부터
납품받아서 그걸 결합해서 만들어서
다시 NVD로 납품하는 이런 방식이
이제 쉬운 방식인데
>> 얘네들은 보니까 HBM을 지금 소위
말하면 어 베이스로 해서 쓰지를 않고
약간 새로운 개념에 칩계를 하고
있더라고요. 그러니까 예를 들면
우리가 TV에서 많이 보셨을 거예요.
이렇게 동그란 웨이퍼 원판에 조그마
반도체들이 이렇게 쌓여 있고 것들을
이제 하나씩 댄게 반도체인데 그걸이
다 이렇게 쉽게 말하면 이렇게 손톱만
하고 이렇게 연결하고 이렇게 하는
건데 얘네들은 야 그렇게 되면이 작은
반도체 하나하나를 또 연결해야 되고
거기서 내서 통신도 돼야 되고 이동도
해야 되잖아. 그냥 나는
웨이퍼 자체를 그냥 하나의 칩으로
해서 이걸 통으로 써. 통으로.
그러면 내부적으로 효율도 엄청
빨라지고 데이터도 열몇 배씩 빨리빨리
다닐 수 있어. 나 그렇게 설계해
볼게라고 하는 사실상의 이제 신개념
신기술을 이제 얘기하는 거거든요.
쉽게 말씀드리면요.
>> 그런가 보다 하면 되는데 문제는
그러면 혹시 HBM을 안 쓰게 되는
건가? 너네들은?
>> 그래서 얘네들이 지금 쓰고 있는 칩은
HBM이 아니고요. 예. 다른
칩이에요. 그래서 어 SRAM이라고
하는
>> S램
>> 예. S램을 쓰고 있는데 쓰게
된다라는 건데 이게 만약에 활성화되고
혹시 얘네들이 시장의 케파를 많이
잡아먹게 되면
>> 전체적으로 HBM이 더 쓰게 될까 덜
쓰게 될까
>> 아직 모르죠.
>> 아직 모르는 그런 이런 어떤 재밌는
의무점을 지금 남기고 있단 말이에요.
예. 그래서 이제 우리가 AI 생태가
어떻게 될 것이며 우리 반도체
업체들이 수출해야 되는 칩이 더
늘어날 것인지 줄어들 것인지 요런
어떤 재밌는 포인트들을 지금 주고
있고요. 더서 더 나가서 고랭앵커님이
예리하게 지적해 주신 거 결국에는
근데 이렇게 성공적으로 IPO가
계속되면 그걸 살려고 하는 자금들이
계속 몰리는데 천문학적 자금이 이제
몰리고 있는데 앞으로도 대기 중이고
그러면 그 돈을 어디서 받아서
청약하느냐 기존에 돈 많이 올랐던
거에서 뺄 수도 있고
>> 기존에이 회사들과 경쟁 관계 있는
회사들 걸 빼서 다시 새로운 데다
넣을 수도 있고 하다 보면
>> 결국에는 그 자금이 한쪽으로 몰리면
M7 또는 나아가서
우리의 이제 삼성이나 하이
>> 많이 수익을 본 자금들이 이쪽으로
빨리는 거 아니냐
>> 그죠?
>> 요런 우려점들이 다양하게 남아 있는
거죠.
>> 네. 맞습니다. 거기다가이 부분에서
한 가지만 더 덧붙여 드리면 올해
미국 시장에서 대형 IPO들이 다
기다리고 있잖아요. 그래서 스페이스
X 오픈 AI 엔트로픽 제가 계산을
해 봤더니 3 4의 기업 가치가 2조
5천억 달러 정도 됩니다. 세 개를
합치면 네. 근데 현재 테슬라의 시가
총액이 1조 6,억 달러, 메타가
1조
5천억 달러, 삼성전자가 달러
기준으로 1조 2,억 달러입니다.
그러니까 이들보다 시가 총액이 합쳤을
때 더 높은 종목들이 이제 상장을
하다 보니
>> 네.
>> 이거 이거 이거 그러면은 테슬라 팔고
메타 팔고 삼성전자 팔고 하는 거
아니야라는 약간의 불안감 있죠.
>> 그렇습니다. 네. 그래서 요런 어
시장에 어쩌면 메기가 한 마리 나온
건가라고는 싶어서 한번 저희가 가지고
와 봤고요. 요런 어떤 최첨단 뉴스
예. 저희가 이렇게 또 이렇게
잡아봅니다네. 네. 마지막 뉴스 함께
확인해 보도록 하겠습니다. 오늘
삼성전자 SK 하이닉스가 빠지면서
함께 빠지는 섹터 바로 전력 기기
관련된 종목들입니다.요 며칠 전만에도
전선주가 또 올라요. 또 올라요
했었는데요.
>> 지금 갑자기 한 이틀 됐나요? 이틀
연속으로 좀 급락이 나오고 있습니다.
현재 가운전선 같은 종목들 20%
넘는 하락세가 나오고 있고요.
>> 음. 대장주라고 할 수 있는 LS
일렉트릭도 현재 6%까지 하락, 효성
중업도 4% 가량의 하락세가 나오고
있습니다. 일단 앞서 저희가 이야기한
그 AI에 관련된 불안함이 반영이
됐고요. 거기다가 지금 구입 가격이
많이 오릅니다. 3% 이상의 강세를
보여주면서 전력 설비 관련된 종목들도
차익 실현이 좀 강하게 나오고
있다라는 점은 우리 투자자 여러분이
조금 알고 계셔야 될 것 같습니다.
>> 아, 네. 중요한 부분입니다. 사실은
이제 어 전체적으로 AI 또는 뭐
AI 생태기 안에 들어 있는 반도체,
전력, 전선, 전기, 배선, 뭐 변합
등등등은 묶어서 가는 거 아니야라고
하니까 멀리 보면 괜찮다라고 생각할
수도 있는데 이게 하루하루 보다 보면
오늘처럼 이렇게 -20이면
어마어마하게 빠진 거예요. 그리고
이제 효성 중공급도 -4가 나오면서
지금 400만 원 선이 무너졌던가요?
>> 네. 380만 원 선입니다.
>> 네. 네. 이렇게 해서 조금 빠질
때는 다소 이제 왜 이러는 거야라고
충격을 받을 수가 있는데요. 예.
그런 부분을 이제 저희가 소개해 드린
거죠. 그래서 이제 원인을 굳이
찾자면음 다소 이제 조금
>> 그동안 너무 많이 올랐기 때문에 조금
부담스러운 국면이 있어서 한 번쯤은
이렇게 횡보하면서 손바힘김도 겪고
조정도 겪는게 자연스러운 국면이에요.
너무 많이 올라가서 사실은
>> 어 반도체만큼 올라가면서 예. 좀
숨게 사실 올라가는 측면도 있거든요.
예. 그리고 마침 또 이제에 이쪽에
이제 필수 원자재인 구류 가격이
올라간게 트리거가 된 거죠. 아
그러면 앞으로 이제 이익이 좀
떨어지는 거 아니야. 이렇게 볼 수
있는 거죠. 예.
>> 그래서 이제 눈여겨 봐야 된다. 묻지
말고 그냥 던져라 뭐 이런 건 아니고
예 또는 어 오히려 저점 매수가 될
수 있겠네 등등등 해서 이런 어떤
유행의에 조금음 트렌드의 약간의
변동감 이런 걸 좀 알고 계셔야
된다라고 해서 저희가 오늘 조금
예리한 뉴스들을 좀 많이 가지고 와
봤습니다.
>> 네. 뉴스 이렇게 정리해 볼까요?
>> 네, 좋습니다. 자, 이렇게 이상
일단 오늘의 복잡한 시장 그다음에
사실 조금 어려운 얘긴데 저희가
디테일까지 한번 짚어 보느라고 오늘
좀 가지고 와 봤고요. 네. 이제
오후장을 대비하는 한 줄 이렇게
변동성 심한 날은 또 우리가 한 줄
정리를 해 드려야 돼요.
>> 아, 그럼군요. 아, 오늘 좀 힘드실
것 같은데 저는 고비가 오늘 밤에
미국장이 될 것 같습니다. 왜냐하면
말씀드린 대로 트럼프 대통령과 시진핑
주석의 합의에서 뭔가 알맹이가
없다라고 생각이 드니까 지금 시작이
빠지는 거거든요. 협상이 지금 협의가
시작이 됐고 여기서 어떤 이야기가
나오고 미국에 오늘 밤에 어떤 영향을
미치고 특히나 백악관 그리고 중국에서
어떤 발표 진짜 숫자적으로 뭔가
발표하는지 확인하셔야 한다라는 걸로
가음해 보도록 하겠습니다.
>> 네. 오늘 밤을 확인하자. 네. 저는
한 말씀드린다면 이렇게
말씀드리겠습니다. 지금 우리가
-3.58 정도 빼고 있거든요.
>> 네.
>> 네. 이건 오바야. 전쟁 났냐?
>> 전쟁 아니잖아.
>> 전쟁 났냐고.
기한 거잖아. 전쟁 이건 오바다.
이렇게 한 줄로 정리하겠습니다.
자, 이제 저희가 정우뉴스 마치고요.
예. 오늘 이광수 대표님의 부제를
틈타서 그 자리를 내가 채우겠다라고
하는 빅스타 사실은 우리가 굉장히
공들여서 예, 섭외에 온 귀빈이시죠.
예. 만나뵙겠습니다네.
네. 12시에 사랑방. 아, 12시
애 사랑방은 아니고요. 12시
사랑방.
>> 네. 오늘 저희가
>> 아, 대단한 분을 모셨습니다.
>> 그럼요. 그럼요.
>> 네. 아, 이분의 별명이 조선의
공모입니다.
>> 대단하십니다. 예. 조선 관련해서는
뭐 타에 추정을 불러하는 우리나라
최고의 애널이시죠. 예. 신용증권의
우리의 아 조선의 국무 엄경아
연구원님을 모셨습니다. 악수
>> 안녕하세요.
>> 처음 뵙겠습니다.
>> 처음 뵙겠습니다.네
>> 우리 독자님들께 인사 한번
부탁드리겠습니다.
>> 예 안녕하세요. 저는 신형증권에서
조선업과 운송을 담당하고 있는
애널리스트 엄경아입니다.네
>> 아니 지금 댓글에도 이미 너무
유명하셔서
>> 아시는 분들이 다 왔어요. 조선 공모
다 왔고 조선이 여신까지 나와
있거든요.
>> 그런 얘기 많이 드시죠? 여신 식모
이런 죄송해요.
>> 예. 뭐 대모 뭐 주모 많이 있죠.
>> 네. 두분은 좀
>> 저희번 나름 주기적으로 이제 뵙는
사이인데 좀 이렇게게 좀 편안하게
얘기할 자리는 아니었어 가지고 저
오늘 되게 기대하고 왔습니다.
>> 그런가요? 제가 불편하게 드렸는데
>> 아닙니다.
>> 아니 저 전부터 되게 궁금했는데 조선
커버리지 하신지는 얼마나 되셨어요?
어 저 이제 올해 12월 되면 만
20년
>> 아 20년이요?
>> 아유 이러니까 이제 국모에 이야기가
나오는 겁니다.
>> 그러면 그 같은 이제 조선 담당하시는
분들 중에서 더 고참이 계셔요?
>> 예 있습니다. 다행히.
>> 몇 명 계세요?
>> 제가 나이로 아마 한네 번째
>> 아 나이 말고이 20년 연차로
>> 연차음
한두 분 계신
>> 네요. 걔네들만 죽으면 되는 거지
그것들만 죽으면 내가 왕인 거죠.
저희
>> 예
>> 다 같이 오랫동안 해야죠
>> 그러면 정말 뭐 꽉잡고 계시겠네요.
어떤 걸 여쭤봐도 항상 다 명쾌하게
답을들을 수 있는 연구원님이시기
때문에 한 가지씩 출발을 해 보도록
하겠습니다. 일단은 저희 방송이 되게
주아가 분들이 보세요. 그래서 진짜
이제 주식 걸음마을 떼시는 분들이
보시기 때문에
>> 네. 신생한 느낌으로 첫 번째로
드리고 싶은 질문은
>> 조선 그래 뭐 배 만드는 거 알겠어.
어 근데 뭐 VCC 뭐 유조선 컨게
도대체 배의 종류가 뭐가 있는 거야?
이거 무슨 말인지 모르겠어라고
여쭤보시는 분들이 많아요.
>> 근데 그 배 종료 약자들 잘 들여다
보면 되게 좀 우습거든요.
>> 방금 그 말씀하셨던 VLCC는 베리,
라지,
>> 크루드
>> 오일 캐리어, 큰 유조선이란
뜻이에요. 아, 좋다. 우리
>> 예, 초대형 유조선 이런 뜻이거든요.
그래서 저희가 그 화물에 따라서 배의
종류를 나눕니다. 그래서 크게는
마른화물, 젖은 그래서 이제 탱커라고
하는 거는 액체류의 화물인데
>> 원래 상원에 있을 때 액체류인 것들이
저희가 이제 유조선에 해당이 되고
있는 거고요. 온에 있을 땐 액체류가
아닌데 액체로 만들어서 액화시켜서
저희가 나르는 것들이 이제 가스
선들이 주로 그런 식이고 이제 마른
화물은 완제품부터 원자재까지 모든
액체류가 아닌 화물들이 이제
건화물이라고 해서 그게 컨테이너가 될
수도 있고 자동차가 될 수도 있고
철광석이 될 수도 있고 곡물이 될
수도 있고 그래서 이렇게 크게 분류를
하고 그 안에 화물 종류에 따라서
저희가 오일을 나르면 오일 탱커 뭐
케미칼을 나르면 케미칼 탱커 이런
식으로 부르는 겁니다. 네. 그라는
그중에서 어느 거를 제일 잘하고
있다라고 평가봤나요?
>> 그 안에서 좀 비싼 거.
쉽게 얘기하 좀 비싼 거를다는
편이고요. 배는 어차피 다 똑같이
생겼는데 뭐가 다를까 싶지만 크기가
커지면 커질수록 만들기가 어렵습니다.
기본적으로 화물이 큰데 여러 개가
실리면 저희가 밸런스가 훼손이 될
수도 있고 이렇게 커다란게 움직여야
된다라는 것 때문에 이제 기술적인
스펙이 좀 많이 들어가기 때문에
기본적으로 모든 화종을 나르는 것
중에서 조금 대형선들이 우리나라가
많이 하는 선방이라고 보시면 될 거
같고요. 기본적으로 화물의 가치가
높을수록 배의 가치도 조금 높은
편이거든요.
까롭을
때에 그래서 어굳이 액을 시키는
과정에 해당하는 그 가스 선들도
굉장히 고부가 선박이라고 저희가 보통
얘기를 하고 어자재를 나르는
선박들보다는 완제품을 나르는 컨테이너
선박 같은 것들 그리고 자동차 운반도
자동차를 나르니까 자동차의 밸류가
철광석보다는 당연히 밸류가 높을
거잖아요. 네업들이
많다라고.
음.
>> 우리가 이제 조선업을 볼 때 사실은
사이클 산업이다.
>> 이런 얘기를 하잖아요. 왜 그런 거고
지금은 어떤 사이클에 와 있나요?
>> 왜 사이클 산업이라고 부르냐면 일단이
배 자체도 내용 연수라는게 있잖아요.
>> 근데 기본적으로 전 세계의 그 해상
물동량이라고 하는 거는 생각보다
그렇게 출렁출렁이면서 왔다 갔다 하지
않는데.
>> 네. 배는 사람이 발을 하는지라가
배도 굉장히 투기적인 시장이거든요.
쏠림 현상이 있을 수밖에 없어요.
>> 그래서 그 많이 발주했던 선박들이 다
늙어 가지고 없어질 때 그때가 이제
그 사이클상으로는
>> 2차 사이클, 3차 사이클이 오는
편에 해당이 되는데
>> 이번에 코로나 팬데믹 이후에는 사실
이미 배들이 많이 늙어서 교체를 해야
되는 그 사이클은 아닙니다. 근데
이제 규제로 시장을 조금 뒤은
상황이라고 보시면 될 거 같은데요.
자동차에서도 기존에 뭐 휘발류 쓰다가
요즘에 전기차로 가듯이 배에서도 어
>> 친환경적인 선박으로 좀 바꿔라라고
하는게 지금이 IMO라고 하는 국제
회사 기구의 그 뜻이라고 보시면 될
거 같고 이거에 맞추려다 보니 기존에
사실 배들이 아마 전 세계에서 제일
더러운 연료 떼면서 다닐 거예요.
커 모든 정과정을 거치고 남은 잔을
저희가 하게 되거든요. 그래서 왜
예전에 트럭에서 막 까만
>> 연기 나는 것처럼 그런 정도 수준의
연료를 쓰는데 이제 이거를 더
친환경적인 연료를 써서 조금 더럽지
않은 기름을 써 가지고 이거를 덜
배출하거나 궁극적으로 나중에 시간이
많이 지나서 한 2050년쯤 되면
I의 CO2를 좀 배출하지 않는
쪽으로 바꿔라고 하는 거라서 지금
>> 한 30년 간의 내용 연수를 다 쓰지
않은 배들도 시장에서 퇴출이 돼야
되는 상황이었습니다. 아,
>> 그래서 전 세계 화물선과 여객선을 다
합쳐서 배가 한 11만 척 정도
있거든요.
>> 근데 지금 시장에서 그래도 벙커보다는
CO2가 덜 나온데라고 인증이 된
연료는 LNG입니다. LNG를 쓰면
한 30% 정도 덜 배출이 되거든요.
그래서 그런 쪽으로 나는 대체 연료를
LNG로 선택하겠어, 뭐 메탄올로
선택하겠어. 이런 식으로 바꿔진게
완료된 선박이
>> 3천척이 안 돼요. 3천척도 안
돼요.
>> 뭐야?
근에 조선업체들이심을
해서 만들 수 있는 선도 2척밖에 안
됩니다.
>> 예. 그래서 저희가 열심히 열심히
이제 계속 바꾸는 과정인데 그러다
보니 교체 수요로 봤을 때는 굉장히
사이클이 초입이다라는 얘기를 저희가
드리는 겁니다.이야
>> 신호선가도 계속 높죠. 신호가는
그래도 한 1년 반 쉬다가 최근에 한
달 전 정도부터 다시 제차 오르기
시작한 상황인데요.
>> 2025년 같은 경우는 너무 피로감을
가지게 성가가 많이 올라서
>> 좀 관망하고
>> 혹시나 빠지지 않을까라는 그런
과정이었다라고 한다면 이럴 때 이제
다시 오르기 시작하는게 조금 무서운
겁니다. 아, 기다려봤자 아무 소용이
없구나라고 결론을 내린 거라고 한다면
이때 이제 성과가 오르게 되면은
오히려 발주도 좀 많이 촉발시키죠.
더 오르기 전에 빨리 발주하는게
낫겠다라는 쪽으로 마음을 먹.
비싸지에.
>> 네. 원래 이제 조선업을 좋아하시거나
투자를 많이 하셔서 관심 많으신 분들
계시겠습니다만은네.
>> 잘 몰라. 그래서 좀 관심이 없었어
하시는 분도 계실 텐데 오늘 그러면
우리
연구원님 말씀들 우리가 다 나가자마자
조선을 사게 되는 건가요?
그게 오늘 목적이에요.
>> 주자 주자분들의
20분간 예. 동국민을 꼬셔보자는
거죠.
>> 아 주아가들이라면서요.
꽃이란 말이요 지금. 그래서 이제
그러면 이제 예리하게 한번 들어가면은
하여간에 그러니까 자동차도 지금 뭐
어
>> 저 예전 디젤 뭐 친환경 안 되는 거
서울에 못 들어오거든요. 그런 식으로
이제 다 퇴는 중이잖아요. 결국에는
지금 11만 척이 돌아다니고 있는데
이제 바뀌어 봐야 3, 4,석이고
3, 4천밖에 안 되고 매년 바뀌어
봐야 2, 3천밖에 안 된다 보면
이거는 뭐 끝도 없이 지금 계속 지금
교체 수이 생긴다라고 하니까 이제
슈퍼 사이클이라고 말씀 주셨는데
그건 너무 이해가 됐어요. 네.
그런데
끝도 없이 생산을 하고 그걸 빨리빨리
바꿔내야 그 많은 수요를 내가 다
먹을 수가 있고 우리 회사가 이익이
폭발적으로 넣을 수가 있는데 방금
말씀드린 것처럼 배를 내가 원한다고
오늘 10열 개 만들 거 내일부터
11 개 만들자 내일 내일부터 20개
만들자 이게 안 되잖아요. 그러니까
대규수원을 엄청 많아도 결국 수주
받아서 만드는 거에 대한이 증가율
수주 잔량의 증가율이 이런 것들은
어느 정도 이렇게 가다 보면 이쪽에서
요렇게 둔화 내리지는 않나요?
>> 네.
>> 둔화될 가능성 당연히 있죠. 네. 저
해운사 입장에서 배 좀 만들어주세요.
찾아갔더니 4년 뒤에 오싶 힘이 쫙
빠지잖아요. 그래서 그게 이제
2025년과 같은 상황이었었고
말씀하셨던 것처럼
>> 어 들어오는 그 계속 많이 만들어야지
좀 커지지 않을까라는 그 시황에
부흥했던 시기가 2007년에서
2010년 사이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 그래서 우리나라 조선
업체들이 2000년부터
한 2010년 정도 사이까지 굉장히
설비 투자를 신규로 하면서 몸집이
푹폭 늘어나는 시기가 있었거든요.
5년에 매출 두 배씩이 이렇게
늘어나는 그런 시기가 있었는데 근데
그렇게 늘려 놓으면 문제는 저희가
건설사가 아니기 때문에 그 설비를
하나 개설해 놓으면은 앞으로도이
설비를 계속 굴릴 수 있을만큼 수주를
받을 수 있다라는 그런 자신감을
가지고 접하지 않 안 되는
상황입니다. 그래서 2013년 정도
이후로 저희가 10년 가량을 쉬는
동안 수주가 모자라니까 매출이 안
되고 그 사업장에 고용되어 있는 그
인원과 그 신규 설비 투자한 그
설비가 안 돌아감으로 인해서 굉장히
장기간 저희가 불황을 겪은
상황이잖아요. 그래서 지금 이번에
이제 시황이 돌아서서 2020년
이후에 굉장히 좋은 시황을 보이고
있는 상황이지만 시장 참여자분들은
오히려 어 여기에서 만약에 섣불리
확대 전략으로 나가면 오히려 그다음에
10년 20년이 굉장히 힘들어질 수
있다라는 생각들을 좀 많이 하시는
편이고 차곡차곡 내가 앞으로 지속
가능하게 유지할 수 있을 정도의
사이즈만 가져간다라는 쪽으로 방향을
잡은 상황이고요. 물론 이럴 때 이제
제일 고민이 되는 순간은 그거죠.
그럼 우리나라 말고
>> 그죠. 다른 데에서는 나는 그럼
늘리겠다라고 늘리면 그
>> 막 빼앗기는 느낌이 굉장히 나는
부분이 있잖아요. 네장전을는
그중밖에 없는 상황이고
>> 어 우리와 함께 그래도 빅 3 안에
들어 있던 일본이
>> 네
>> 너무 희마리가 없이 지금 자꾸
줄어들고 있는 상황이 되고 있어서
완전한 이강 체제의 모습을 좀
갖춰가고 있는데 여기에서 우리는 챙길
걸 챙기고 어 여기에서 실질적으로
앞으로 계속 늘려갈 수 있는 부분에
대해서만 집중하자.
앞으로 만약에 시장이 좀 과해진다고
하면 분명히 가격이 굉장히 높아질
것이고요. 그거를 그냥 취하는 쪽으로
방향을 잡지 않을까?
>> 안도 차고 비슷하네요. 양을
늘리기보다는
>> 그렇게 부족하면 너네가 비싸게 사.
>> 그렇죠. 살면 비싸게 사든가. 올릴
때
>> 급하면 돈 쓰면 되지 뭐.
>> 그렇지. 네.
>> 돈 없으면 사지 마.
>> 배가 뭐 야 그렇게 쉽게 나오는
거야?
>> 네. 그러면요.이 배산업을 조선업을
하고 있는 우리
>> 소위 말한 이제 3대장이라고 우리는
알고 있는데
>> 어떤 회사들인가요? 일단 울산에 있는
회사와 거제도에 있는 회사 나눌 수가
있습니다. 울산인에 있는 회사는 다
아시다시피 저희 울산의 이제 과거
사명 기준으로 현대중공업 지금은 HD
현대 중공업으로 이제 바뀐 쪽이고요.
거기가 전체 조선 업체, 3대 조선
업체 중에 가장 생산 설비를 많이
가지고 있다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 어 드라이도크라고 하는 그
파진 땅의 모양을 14개를 보유를
하고 있고요.
거지는
조선업체는 한군는 한군는 하나오이라고
보시면 될 거 같은데
>> 각각 생산설비 보유대수 기준으로 하면
삼성은 기존에 여덟 개를 가지고
있었는데 지금은 현재 여섯 개를
운영을 하고 있고요. 어 하나오션
같은 경우는 과거에 일곱 개를 운영을
했었는데 어 저희 안 좋을 때 좀
없애 버려서 지금은 현재 다섯 개를
운영을 하고 있는데 내년부터는 다시
여섯 개를 운영을 할 예정입니다.
네.음이
3대 조선사들이 사실 실적이 다 계속
좋잖아요.이
>> 실적이 어디까지 갈 거냐 이런 것들도
이야기 많이 하시더라고요. 실적은
사실 올해는 뭐 걱정 안 해도
된다라고 계속 말씀하셨던 걸로
기억하거든요. 올해 내년 아마 올해
말쯤 되면은 내 후년까지도
괜찮아요라는 얘기를 제가 드릴 수
있을 것 같아요. 그래서 2020년
여름부터 2024년
>> 3분기 말까지 선박의 가격이 계속
올랐습니다. 그 사이에 저희는 계속
또 수주를 했었겠죠. 그래서 지금
2026년 상반기 현재 기준으로 지금
만드는 배은 저희가 23년에 수주한
배들이 제일 많아요. 그러니까 여전히
24년에 수주한 배를 만들 때까지
계속 저의 그 제품 단가는 올라가고
있는 상황이겠죠. 그런데 25년에이
달러 기준 성가가 또 조정을 받을 때
환율이 또 좋았어 가지고 국내 조선
업체들 입장에서는 원화 기준으로
수주한 선가는 계속 상승세를 탔다라고
보셔도 될 거 같습니다. 그래서 지금
이번 1분기에 3사가 합산 기준 영업
이익이 2조원을 처음으로 상회를
했거든요. 그리고 대부분 이제 두
자릿수의 영업 이익률을내는 거에
대해서 크게 부담이 없을 만한 환경이
좀 조성이 된 상황입니다. 그래서
내년 내후년까지 만들게 되면 어 배
만들어서 이익 한 20% 남기는 거는
조금 쉬운 일이 되겠다라고 저희가
생각을 해 볼 수 있을만큼 눈높이를
조금 더 높여도 될 만한 상황이고요.
어 여기에서 이제 막 다시 성과가
고개를 다시 반등하면서 좀들은
상태니까 어느만큼까지 올라줄 것인가
좀 관건인 그다음 스텝은 그래서
저희가 좀 지켜봐도 될 만한
상황이라고 보시면 될 것 같아요.
>> 네.이 이 3 4의이
뭐 특당점들이 조금씩 다른가요?
>> 누가 뭘 잘해라고 물어보면 조금씩
차이가 있다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 일단 사이즈가 제일 큰
현대중공업 같은 경우는
>> 어 기본적으로 조선의 본업에 해당하는
상선을 가장 많이 생산을 하는 편이고
예전부터 사이즈가 월등이 크게 그
사업을 진행을 했었기 때문에
기본적으로 많은 시리즈의 선박이 발주
나오는 거에서의 그 수주 강점을
갖습니다.
>> 네. 컨테이너 선박 같은 쪽에서의 그
누적 적수가 가장 많은 업체라고
보시면 될 거 같고요. 저희 거제도에
있는 두 계사들은 어 기본적으로
지금까지 지구상에 깔려 있는 LNG
캐리어를요 두 개 회사가 거의 1,
2등을 다투면서 많이 만들었던
업체들이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
그래서 상선에서는 사실 근데 현대가
만든 컨테이너가 더 좋아, 뭐 대우가
만든 데가 더 좋아.
가 더 좋아 이제는 거의 차이가 없을
만큼이라고 볼 수가 있는데이 기존의
상선 말고 다른 사업에서 이제 조금씩
차이가 많이 나고 있는 상황이다라고
보시면 될 거 같고요. 어 HD 헌드
그룹 같은 경우는 일단 국내에서 방산
진행하고 있는 회사 중에 하나입니다.
그래서 현대는 방산 중에서도 수상함에
조금 특징을 많이 가지고 있는 편이고
그 거제도에 있는 하나오션 같은
경우는 또 똑같이 방산을 진행을 하고
있는데 수상함보다는 조금 잠수함의
주장점을 많이 가지고 있는
특징이고요. 두 회사와 달리 어 방의
산업을 진행하지 않고 있는
삼성준공업이지만 삼성준공업은 해양
플랜트 쪽에 그 역량을 여전히 조금
크게 가져가고 있는 편이라서이 조선
외 사업에서 이제 그런 차이가 있고
굉장히 특이하게 조선 사업을 진행을
할뿐만 아니라 엔진도 내부적으로
진행을 하고 있는 업체가 지현대
그룹이라고 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
이제 삼성중공업 한화 모션 얘네들은
쉬운데이
>> 현대 쪽은가 보면
>> 복잡해요 회사 이름이
>> 아 네
>> 예 사월에 8종까지 다 있는 거 같고
>> 그래도 하나 줄었어요.
>> 아 그럼요. 미포가
>> 쉽게 그냥 어떻게 뭐어 어떻게이
상장사만 지금네 개예요 얘네들
>> 더 많죠.
>> 그니까 요요 조선 해양 밑에만요.
그죠? 어떻게 좀 쉽게 한 큐에
정리됩니까? 어, 지금 현재 상장
코드 기준으로 009540 저희
예전에 현대중공업이었던 그 회사가
지금 현재 기준으로는 HD 한국
조선양이 되어 있습니다.이
>> 밑에 조선소가 두 개 일단 붙어
있는데요. 조선소 하나는 아까 제가
지금까지 얘기했던 울산에 있는 HD
현대 중공업이 회사이고 나머지 하나는
그 영암쪽 목포에 있는데 있는 HD
현대 3호라고 하는 회사를 지금이
회사가 밑에
>> 두 개를 두고 있는 상황이고요.
>> 음. 어 나중에 그룹사가 아니었었는데
인수를 한 회사 중에 예전에 STX
중공업이라고 하는 엔진 회사가
있었는데 그 회사를 인수를 해서 HD
현대 마린 엔진이라고 하는 걸로 또
사명을 바꿨어요. 그래서 지금이 HD
한국조선이라고 하는 조선 중간지 회사
밑에는 조선소 사업장 두 개와
엔진사장이 하나 그리고 태양광회사도
하나이 밑에 딸려 있는 상황이다라고
보시면 될 것 같습니다. 네. 그러면
예를 들어서 하나 삼성은 그냥 어
내가 마음에 들어 비전이 너무 좋아
그럼 그렇게 사면 되는데 예를 들어서
이제 HD 현대 개어를 사면은 방금
말씀하신 것처럼 어 울산의 14개를
직접 들고 있는 현대 중공업이 있고
그 위에 지주격인 예 한국 조선
해양이 있고
>> 네네
>> 그다음에 나머지 둘은 뭐 엔진
쪽이니까 그렇다고 빼도 하면이 둘
간에
>> 뭘 사야 돼요
>> 일단 마음에
게 좋아. 이러신 분들한테는 저는
그냥 현대중공업 사시라고 말씀을
드려요. 왜냐면 조선이라고 하는 그
주제에서 여러 가지가 이렇게 언급이
되잖아요. 근데 거기에 다 해당이
됩니다.
>> 음.
>> 엔진도 본인이 하고 있죠. 방산도
본인이 하고 있죠. 해양도 하고 있고
상선도 하고 있기 때문에. 네. 네.
저희가 이제 그 HD조선향을 저는
조금 더 선호를 하는 편인데
>> 그 이유는이
그룹이 지금 해외에서도 조선업을
진행을 하는 부분이 있거든요. 그래서
그 해외 야드들에 대한 투자 법인을
한국 조선회양이 더 많이 들고
있습니다. 그쪽이 최대 주주라서
결국이 그룹에서 진행하는 모든 국내외
조선업과 관련된 것은 다 한국 조선
해양으로 몰리는 그런 구조를 가지고
있기 때문에 으흠. 좀 돈 많이 벌면
또 주주들한테
>> 환원하잖아요. 그래서 그러한 부분도
많이 누리실 수 있기 때문에 조선업이
좋아지는 거에 대한 주가 상승분과
그리고이 주주환원에 따른 배당 수익도
같이 누려볼 수 있다라는 그리고 측면
그리고 조선업이 이제 한국에서의 좀
고민은 그것도 있거든요. 어, 근데
더 많이 못 만들기 시작하면 내가이
성장성이 좀 제한적이라고 볼 수 있는
주식에 투자를 하는게 좋을까라는 그런
걱정을 할 수가 있는데 그런
부분에서의 이제 해외 확장성을 가져갈
수 있다라는 것 때문에 저희는 조금
더 중간 추천.
>> 아, 네. 여러분, 오늘 그래도
우리가 꿀팁이 나왔습니다.
>> 제가 그랬죠. 시원시원하시다고.
>> 울산에 있는 14개 조선소가 너무
좋아 그러면 예. HD 현대
중공업이고 나머지 엔진 뭐 태양강
그다음에 해외 조선의 어떤 뭐 인수
등등등까지 다 노리려면 그 위에 있는
지주사 HD 한국 조선 해양을 관심
가져 보시면 되겠다라는 건데요.
알겠습니다.
>> 네. 어 마스가 이야기도 좀 확인해야
될 거 같아요. 사실 제일 기다리고
있는 이슈 중에 하나긴 하잖아요.
뭔가 진행이 되고 있는 것 같긴
하더라고요. 뭐 M 맺은 거 맞죠?
최근에 이제 갔다 오셨잖아요.
그래가지고 워싱턴 DC의이 조선업과
관련된 투자하는 이제 협력 기구를 좀
구체적으로 만들고이 부분에서 이제
협력을 좀 진행해 보자라고 얘기가
나와서 작년까지는 마스가라는 단어는
나왔는데 아무것도 진행이 된게 없고
근데이 와중에도 조용조용하게 마로는
또 발주가 나오고 있었거든요. 아,
그래요? 이제 올해는 뭔가 구체적
>> 마가 뭔가요? O
>> 유지보수.
>> 유지보수죠. 네.
>> 유지보수를 왜 할까요?
>> 왜 하는 거예요?
>> 왜 할까요?
>> 안 살려고.
>> 부함이 너무 늙어서 회이 되기 전에
저희가 생명 연장하려고 하는 겁니다.
그래서 MR를 열심히 한다라는 건
지금 사실 신규 근함이 엄청 필요한데
이게 지금 여건이 안 되다 보니
이걸로 틀어막고 있는
>> 쓰는 거죠. 어지로네.
아무튼 마스가 프로젝트가 이제
구체적으로
곧 발동이 되는 거죠. 그래서 이제
뭐 돈의 규모 1,500억 달러는
조선업에 투자했으면 좋겠다였었고 이제
거기에서 나온 것 중에 아 미국에서
무조건 투자해 가지고 진행하는 거
아니고 어 해외에서 만들어 가지고
와도 되니까 이거에 대해서 이제 그
협력을 좀 구체화해 보자라는 얘기
정도기 때문에 올해는 뭐가 되었건
하나라도 어 가동이 되지 않을까라고
생각나
그 프로젝트가 가동이 되면 사실은 그
낙수 수의 효과를 우리 업체들이
보면서 뭐 미국도 좀 윈고 우리도
윈데
>> 그런 구조가 잘 만들어지고 있나요?
저희는 만들어질 수 있다라고
생각하는게 미국도 그렇다고 해서
군함을 막 100% 아웃소싱하면서
손을 놓지는 않을 거잖아요. 그러면
미국에서 원래 그 비즈니스를 진행하고
있는 업체들은 결국 끝까지 갈 거고
그들의 생산성이 너무 안 나오는 거를
도와주는 방향으로 아마 그 사업이
진행이 되게 될 텐데 그런 업체들과
국내에 있는이 대기업들이 협력 관계를
좀 공고히 가져가고 있는 상황이라서
저희가 헌팅턴 인걸스 쪽이랑 협력을
하고 있는 HD 현대 그룹이나
아니면은 그 제너럴 다이나믹스 밑에
있는 나스코랑 협력을 하고 있는
삼성중공 같은 업체들에게 직접
본인들이 수주를 하지 않는다고
하더라도 매출로 실현이 되는 그
부분을 오히려 빠르게 확인할 수 있지
않을까 생각하고 있습니다.
>> 네. 근데 이제 마스가 프로젝트가
어쨌거나 총액으로는 정해졌잖아요.이
정도 우리가 투자한다. 그리고 뭐 2
몇십년까지 뭐 얼마 한다. 그러면
그게 뭐 발주가 됐든 MR가 됐든 뭐
군함에 어쩌고 저쩌고가 됐든 대충
느낌은 오는데 지금 아까 말씀드린
것처럼 우리가 이제이 조선업체 주가를
볼 때 수주 잔량도 봐야 되고 뭐
어쩌고 저쩌고 성장성도 봐야 되고
그럼 지금이 주가가 그걸 어느 정도
반영하고 있겠구나 생각할 수는 있는데
마스가 자체를 지금 주가가 반영하고
있다고 봐야 돼요. 아니면 아직 이제
본격적으로 터지면 이것도 더 수혜가
더 올라갈 거라서 좀 덜 반영됐다
이렇게 봐야 될까요? 마스가는 저희는
더 반영될 여지가 조금 많다라고
보는게 아까 말씀드렸다시피
>> 어 우리의 지금 현재 인프라를 활용을
해서
하게 되었을 때 실제로 여기에서 이제
모듈 형태로 저희가 매출을 일으키게
되면 지금 현재 한국에 있는 사업을
뭘 더 늘리거나 이러지 않아도 되는
상황인데요. 미국의 군남과 관련된
예산의 그 책정 규모 자체가 한국
전체 조선 업체가 만드는 상선 전체
규모보다 큽니다. 음.
>> 그래서 일부만 저희가 할 수 있는
부분이 생긴다라고 해도 국내 조선
업체들 입장에서는 유럽 굉장히 대규모
선주들이 막 돈 싸들고 이렇게 오는
거와 같은 효과를 볼 수가 있거든요.
그래서 아직까지 국내 조선 업체들의
주가에는 저희는 반영이 되지
않았다라고.
>> 오. 오,
>> 그럼 어쨌거나 마스가는 그 사실상 뭐
상선도 있습니다만 고함 관련해서
우리가 생각을 많이 하니까 음이
>> 두 회사가 그래도 조금 수혜를 더 볼
수 있겠네요.
>> 군남을 기존에 해봤던 업체들 같은
경우는 군남 프로젝트에서 조금 이점을
가져갈 수 있을 거라고 보고 있고요.
근데 미국이 그뿐만 아니라 이렇게
여러 나라에서 이렇게 국지전을 하면서
느낀 거는 전투함도 전투함인데 물자가
제 시간에 도달을 하는 거에 대한
부분이 굉장히 중요하다라는 거를 많이
생각을 하면서 군수 쪽에서도 군수
지원함의 중요도가 올라온 것도 있고
그리고 기본적으로 모든 국가에는
전략상선이라고 하는게 있습니다.
평소에는 해운업을 그냥 상업적으로
진행을 하지만 전시에는 전쟁에 투입이
돼야 되는 그런 선박들의 선대를
가져가게 되는데
>> 그 부분이 지금 굉장히 줄고 오후화
되어 있는 상황이라서 그런 부분에
대한 투자도 진행을 한다라고 하는데
이건 또 한국 업체들이 원 잘하던
부분이니까 그러한 부분이 나오게 돼도
이제 국내 조선 업체들에게는 굉장히
큰 도움이 되지 않을까?
>> 네. 뭐 미국 마스가나 군함 얘기해서
또 이제 최근에 관심을 모으고 있는게
캐나다 잠수함 그거잖아요.
>> 지금 업계에서 어떻게 보고
있을까요?음
>> 이게 이제 저희가 한 줄게 몇 뭐
몇십조입니까 그게? 60도 아,
60조 얘기가 나오고 네. 이거를
설비를 신규로 만드는 거에 대한
부분만 60조는 아닙니다. 어 저희가
한 12개 정도의 잠수함에 대한
얘기가 나오고 있는 상태이고 잠수함
하나의 가격은 뭐 1조에서 1.5조
정도 실질적으로 한 뭐 12조에서 한
18조 정도의 규모가 될 텐데요.
만들고 나서 이제 마지막에 퇴할
때까지 그 라이프 사이클 동안 필요로
하는 그 모든 케어에 들어가는 그 총
비용을 통수로서 저희가 60조의
규모다라고 얘기를 하는 겁니다. 근데
원래 영국에서 도입한 그 잠수함이
완전히 퇴역되어서 다른 쪽으로
프로그램을 바꾸는 과정에서이 시작된
부분이기 때문에 적은 규모의
프로젝트가 당연히 아니고 여기에서
이제 저희가 시작을 하게 되면 그거에
연계되어 있는 MRO 사업까지
확장해서 할 수 있다라는 부분인
거잖아요. 그래서 어 가능성에
대해서를 굉장히 많이 물어보시지만
이거에 대해서 이제 우리나라 정부
관계에서 어떻게 얘기했었냐면 49대
51이다라고 조금 우리가 49 거죠.
네.
>> 그것도 뭐라고 얘기할 수 없는
상황이에요. 왜냐면 캐나다 입장에서
그래서 이제 지금 독일이랑 한국이
경합을 하고 있는데
>> 여기에서 이제 내놓은 것이
그거든요.이
어차피 잠수함은 이제 도입을 해야
되긴 하는데 이거 말고도이 캐나다
시장에 뭔가 좀 도움이 될 만한 뭐
공장 뭐 이렇게 도입시켜 주세요.
일자리 이렇게 늘 이런 거에 대한
요구 사항이 굉장히 있는 거잖아요.
네려는
아니기 때문에이 주변 상황에 대한
것까지 다 이루어진 상태에서 결론이
나는데 여기에서 저희가 잠수함 저희는
모델까지 나와 있는 겁니다. 무조건
잘 될 거요라는 얘기를 하는게 무슨
의미가 있냐는 거죠. 음.
>> 그리고 지금은 이제 결론이 이전에
시장에서 온갖 카더라와 추측과 이런
것이 많을 수밖에 없는
>> 근데 결론은 언제나요?
>> 어, 빠르면 상반기. 네.
>> 상반기. 그러니까 얼마 안 남았네요.
한한 달. 네. 진짜 아무도 모르는
거.
>> 만약에 되면은 근데 이제 아까 얘기한
한화랑 현대랑 반반 들어가는 거예요.
>> 네. 원팀으로 들어갔기 때문에 그렇긴
하는데 잠수한 프로젝트는 해외에서
진행을 할 때 아마 하나가 조금 더
우선권을 가져가는 편이고요. 수상한
프로젝트 같은 경우는 원팀으로
들어갔을 때 현대 쪽이 조금 더
우선권을 갖는 쪽이 될 것 같습니다.
음. 아무튼 지금 우리가 조선을
모태로 해서 조선 안에 들어 있는
방산도 봤는데 여기다 또 기능이 하나
더 최근에 얹어진 거 아니냐라고 해서
뭐야 조선이대 왜 AI야라고 해가
지금 AI 생태이 아니라 갑자기
조선이 또 엮겨 들어가고 있어요.
이건 어떻게 봐야 될까요?
>> 이뭐 엔진으로 발주한다는데 이게
뭔가요? 진도 그렇고 막 지금 데이터
센터를 뭐 만들어서
띄운다 뭐 이런 얘기
>> 념 설계 정도가 이제 삼성 중공업에서
들어가 있는 상태인 거 같고요. 어
배는 사실 육상에서 할 수 있는 모든
일을
>> 바다 위에서도 할 수 있게 만드는게
베니다. 아,
>> 그래서 우리나라 조선업체들이 그 해양
플랜트 쪽에서도 막 심용 해양 플랜트
이런 걸 되게 잘하는 이유가
>> 네.
원래 땅에서 해야 되는 거를 바다에서
할 수 있게끔 만드는 그 기술이 잘
되어 있기 때문이거든요. 그래서
만약에 데이터 센터를 저희가 육상에
안 짓고 바다에 지으면 어떤 이점이
있냐면 어 냉각수를 그냥 해수로
활용해서 할 수 있기 때문에 그러한
쪽에서의 이점도 있고 이거에 앞서서
저희가 뭐 왜 선방용 엔진이 갑자기
데이터 센터에 들어간다는 얘기가
나오냐라고 하는 거의 문제는 그냥
전력이 겁나 부족한 겁니다. 예.
엄청 부족한데이
전력에 대해서 수급이 지금 안
되잖아요. 저희 발전소 짓는 거
굉장히 느리고. 네 그럴 때이
형태를 가지고이 선이 들어가는 발전엔
활용을 하면 빠르게 전력을 저희가
공급을 할 수가 있거든요. 기본적으로
원래도 바다에 떠다니고는 빌딩에다가
저희가 발전소 하나 넣어 주는 기능을
하는게 발전 엔진고 그게 앞으로
나아갈 땐 추진 엔진이 들어가는
거라서 원래도 국가의 전력망이
촘촘하게 다 있지 않은 국가들의
선방용 엔 발전 엔진을 여러 세트를
이렇게 합쳐서 저희가 납품을 하면
그게 급성으로 저희가 발전소 역할을
하는 부분을 수급을 할 수가
있습니다. 네발전엔수요산
A라 그지 AI 뭐 저희가 처음으로
납품을 한다 이건 아니고 원래 저희는
육상용 발전으로 굉장히 납품을 많이
했었던 레퍼들을 가지고 있습니다.
네.
>> 그럼 이것도 또 생각 못한
보너스네요.
>> 뭐 전방 산업이 하나 더 확대가 되는
부분이기 때문에 굳이 뭐 안 할 필요
있겠어 하 하면 되지라고 생각하면 될
거 같아요.
>> 네. 그렇다면 뭐 좋은 이야기를 싹
다 돌아봤는데 투자자의 측면에서
조선주 투자할 때 요거 요거 요거는
좀 체크해 보시고 조심할
부분입니다라고
하는 거는 뭐가 있을까요?
>> 수주 산업이잖아요. 근데 수주가
나와야 될 이유가 만약에 사라진다.
그건 가장 안 좋은 상황입니다.
그래서
>> 뭐
>> 이제 전망하는 사람 입장에서는 항상
좋은 얘기 드리고 싶죠.
뭐 지금 3천척밖에 안 바뀌어서
앞으로 바뀔게 막 11만 척이 넘게
남막 이런 얘기 드릴 수 있지만
기술의 발전이라고 하는 거는 언제든
변수를 가져올 수 있기 때문에 저희가
굳이 배를 세걸로 바꾸지 않았는데도
불구하고 그 규제에 맞게끔 할 수
있는 기술이 그 사이에 개발이 될
수도 있는 부분인 거거든요. 그래서
그러한 큰 트렌드가 바뀌는 소식이
있는지 없는지 저희는 그거는 체크를
하면서 가야 된다라고 생각을 하고
있고요. 어, 여기에서 만약에 지금은
저희가 봤을 때 시장 참변자가 아무도
그런 모습을 보이지 않고 있는 편에
해당이 되긴 하는데 어,
2007년에서
그 10년 사이 움직임이 다시
나타난다. 막
>> 다 물라방처럼 달려드면
>> 다 투자해
>> 조선나 조선 이렇게 된다 그러면 예,
사이클 꺼질 수 있습니다. 실질적으로
그 두 가지고 한 가지만 더 여쭤보고
싶은게 사실 그저께가요? 뭐 파업
이야기 나오면서 주가 흔들리더라고요.
지금 삼성전선자 때문에 워낙 난리라서
진짜로 파업의 이슈가 생길 수 있는지
그러면 주가에 어떤 영향을 주게 될지
두 가지 궁금해집니다.
>> 제가 커버했던 20년 동안은
조선소에서 파업 이슈가
>> 지나치게 장기화 됐던 점은 없었던 거
같습니다.
>> 네.
이렇게
>> 잘 해결하시더라고요.
>> 크게 뭐
>> 알겠습니다.
>> 그치료네
사실 예 더 오래 말씀 나눠도
좋을만큼 지금 말씀 너무 편안하고
쉽게 쉽게 잘해 주셨는데
>> 시간이 다 돼 버렸어요.
>> 아 아쉬워라. 근데 오늘처럼 막 사실
이제 장이 좀 시끌시끌하고 뭐
변동성이 심한 날 오히려 이런 날
너무 이일비 하시면서 막 계속
보시면서 안절부절 하시는 거보다는
살짝 덮어 놓고 이럴 때 이렇게
>> 공부도 좀 하고요.
>> 오늘 공부 많이 되셨을 거예요.
>> 예. 그동안 또 반도체 반도체 이분
보셨는데 아니야. 이렇게 하면서 이제
최고의 전문가 이렇게 모시고
>> 공부를 좀 나눠봤는데 너무
부족했어요. 시간이 다음에는 그냥
통으로 예. 한 번 더 한 번 더
>> 한 번 더가 뭐야 주기적으로
보시겠습니다네.
>> 어떠셨어요 오늘?
>> 아 재밌었습니다.
>> 재밌었어요.
>> 또 오실 거죠?
>> 아이 그럼네
>> 아무튼 이렇게 귀한 시간 내셔 가지고
우리 예 위원님 너무나
감사드립니다.네
저희가 끝날 때 항상 레터를 읽어
드리는데요. 예 오늘은 그냥
생략하도록 하겠습니다.
>> 다음 주에 봐요.네
>> 요게 임시 MC의에에
엉망 징창 진행의 백미 아니겠습니까?
예. 아무튼 오늘 또 이번 주 한 주
예, 거침없이 우리 코스피
달려오느라고 숨 많이 찼는데요. 예,
다소 어, 쉬어간다라고 생각하시고
편안한 마음으로 오후 보내시고요.
저희는 주말 잘 지내고 또 미중 회담
결과까지 딱 모아 가지고 월요일에 또
좋은 소식과 함께 찾아뵙도록
하겠습니다. 오늘 방송 여기서
마치겠습니다. 감사합니다.
>> 안녕.